here with more is the award-winning
actor filmmaker co-founder of core his
name is uh actor sean penn how are you
thanks for coming in appreciate it
uh i want to start this anyway so i made
a phone call to you i read that you were
there
and the story interested me
uh if you were on this set 99 out of 100
times we probably would be
in full disagreement right question
about that all right so i make the first
phone call to you i don't know if you
remember
and i said i'm interested in the work
that you're doing and why you were there
even before the war started in this
documentary you're doing you remember
what you first said to me
i do what'd you say i said that i don't
trust you
is there a reason you didn't trust me
yeah there's a lot of reasons i don't
trust you but my trust or your trust you
know there's so many uh people that
don't trust their spouse and yet we've
got to get on with life and we've got
a situation i've never felt this way
about where our country is and what i
experienced emotionally
in ukraine where it had not we all talk
about how divisive things are how
divided things are here but when you
step into a country of such incredible
unity you realize what we've all been
missing and i don't think that we i've
got time to indulge my lack of trust
which it becomes a petty thing as people
and babies are being vaporized and that
these people are fighting for the very
dreams they're the aspiration of all of
us americans and we talked about that
too we don't really agree on that that
there's that we've got to take their
example
we'll worry about political
disagreements if you ever want to come
back another day you're always invited
here's what i want to know
you were there in november of 2021.
okay
we really
we're not even talking about the real
lead-up to this conflict at by that
point right
why were you there originally to do a
documentary what was it about ukraine or
maybe it was about zielinski that
interested you well i think i was uh on
a better part of the population most
americans in any and any
understanding of of ukraine what was
ukraine who was ukraine where was
ukraine with the exception of a phone
call between president zlinski and
president trump that was made a lot of
and and and the fact that president
zolinski had been a comedic actor who
had played a character that then became
the president and then became the
president we went initially to make a
documentary that had
brought would bring home a sense of
ukraine and a profile of this president
but it wouldn't have been as interesting
and then the next thing you do is you
see this buildup of vladimir putin on
the eastern side of ukraine right you
got first we have 50 000 troops then
it's 100 000 troops and all the military
equipment and you're you're chronicling
all of this
and you develop a relationship with
zielinski yeah tell us as as this was
unfolding a lot of the world didn't
think that putin would do it i did think
he would
you know all the experts i talked to
thought that he would most of the
experts that that were speaking out the
united states intelligence agency and
and others
felt that he would i'll tell you that to
the last minute i think the part of me
the part of me that would want to not be
in denial of what that would mean uh to
ukraine and ultimately to the world
uh i i thought
really does is there an upside to this
for him but what i wasn't you know
really savvy to
was that
i gather you and uh but but in
particular you know well
so universally
the the experts on the on putin
felt this was going to happen
and
what didn't happen therefore were the
preemptive sanctions on enough of a
dramatic level before he was so deep in
that the humiliation wasn't going to let
it stop
and that you weren't going to have the
simplicity of negotiations for regions
of the east or maropoul to be able to
make the bridge from crimea and now it
was going to be this full-on assault and
here we are okay
prior to zelinski i didn't know a whole
lot about zilinski like a lot of people
until the infamous phone call
i still to this day think there was
nothing to that phone call separate
issue but he had taken georgia putin had
taken georgia in oh wait he annexed
crimea in 2014
he has shown a willingness
to
annex take over
land showing his territorial ambitions
so you get there you're interviewing
zielinski at this time did he see this
coming did he believe that this was real
well it's interesting because we had we
had met initially on a zoom call uh the
back uh oh god did you trust him
i was really interested to see who he
was easy yeah and and and i didn't have
the baggage with him i have with you
um but what is the baggage we never met
before
well actually i have a i have as a
television is that no there's a badge of
honor in my house i've got the full
screen that i dominate as an enemy of
the state with you and
i don't remember it's a true thing so
but but here's what happened is that
then because of covet
once we had gotten you know a sense that
he was very much considering giving us
some kind of access and and spending
some time with us uh we were delayed and
we were delayed and so then we went uh
back we started in the shooting in
november we went to mario paul to on the
front lines and then we also were in
kiev and talking to
um you know musicians and you get a
sense of the culture but there was the
um
you know the wagner problem that was
going on at the time and so the
administration was very so we couldn't
see him
we came back and then this thing really
escalated so then we went i think we got
there i don't know roughly a week before
the invasion
and we met him
i met him face to face for the first
time the day before the invasion
and then spent time with him in which we
documented in the film on during the
invasion on the day of the invasion and
i don't know that there's a person on
earth who who could know that they were
born for such a day that they could rise
to it i want to make sure
paige when you say invasion was this him
taking the two region dumbass dumbass
etc or well there were also rockets
coming in this is also when they this is
when they took the airport 15 clicks out
of right cube so
it was it was game on
and so to
in him i saw something that i've never
seen before uh in my lifetime
um
that
like i said having seen him yes prepared
for it
yes
hoping against hope it would not happen
but a man who'd not yet been challenged
with it's happening and the next day i
saw something that is a man but it's a
man
with the adrenalized
he's the face of something that you see
in all the ukrainians we saw and talked
to whether they were in uniform out of
uniform school teachers even children
this extraordinary courage that's come
up and he it was in his eyes and
it is clear to me that the ukrainians
will win this the question is at what
cost did they have in those early hours
i know that trump gave them javelins i
know that they had some defenses but if
you go back to the budapest agreement
they were at the time the third largest
nuclear power in the world and they they
made an agreement that they'd give those
weapons to the
to russia to be destroyed in exchange
for protection from russia great britain
and the u.s
lesson to be learned here don't give up
your nuclear weapons if you have them
because you can't believe people like
vladimir putin well even countries that
have nuclear weapons can remain
intimidated to use them and we're seeing
that now with our own country and i fear
what that legacy is going to be we don't
no one wants to see a nuclear company i
don't want to see one
nobody at the same time if only one
bully is going to be able to use those
weapons as a threat we've got to rethink
what we're doing see i think the west
made a mistake in in this buildup that
putin as he brought in ten thousand
troops and twenty thousand and we get up
to a hundred thousand and it became very
clear transparent and obvious that he
was going to go in and all the military
equipment with it at that point i
thought nato countries and western
european countries and the u.s should
have anticipated what was pretty obvious
and been arming the ukrainians for that
moment and i don't think they were
prepared either am i wrong
well
look this could happen tomorrow also we
can get f-15s f-16s and then they can
fly those with three weeks of training
they can fly the migs in the sus now
we know that not from sean penn we know
that from the california national guard
who has had a 30-year
exercise training mutual with ukraine
and were there with the ukrainian
aviators just shortly before they were
pulled out because this of the the
politics and the policies are related to
this
you know impending invasion now invasion
so i i think we re we really have to
rethink
this because these this is these are at
this point
truly humanitarian mechanisms i want to
get to what you've seen but i want to go
back to this question
poland offered what was 28 or 29 migs
yeah
every report says joe biden vetoed that
forget politics i think he made the
wrong call i think he should have green
lights not everybody said everybody says
he vetoed it and i'm not and i'm not
gonna all right whoever vetoed it the
lottery
some people say that something that was
meant to be covert got leaked and became
overt and that that compromised these
nato partners i that what matters to me
is and what's true is is for a squadron
which is
you know two squadrons is probably what
it would take from everyone that's an
expert i talked to to end this thing and
and that's that's that's about 300
million dollars one billionaire could
pay for those planes if the nato
countries would let them overfly in and
and deliver them all right i
i look at
and i've had arguments with a lot of my
friends here i i i do not believe
i think if we learn from recent history
that politicians republicans and
democrats they're all gung-ho they start
these wars they don't fight them to win
them they they start the war gung-ho
then they politicize the war then we
lose our national treasure our sons and
daughters then others come home with
debilitating injuries lost limbs legs
arms
you know deformities that you can't even
imagine i've met many of them in the
course of my life and then they say
never mind and like the disaster in
afghanistan they pull out so i'm not for
one boot on the ground
ronald reagan had a doctrine and the
doctrine was in the case of the former
soviet union invading afghanistan in the
80s he supplied stinger missiles to the
mujahideen by the way not perfect
partners by any means
and they were able to defeat the former
soviet union he helped the nicaraguan
freedom fighters the contra rebels
against the sandinistas and daniel
ortega okay i support that doctrine
i support the trump doctrine that if
you're going to fight a war you push
buttons using new military weaponry and
technology and you bomb the living i
call it adam schiff you bound the ship
out of but i would argue you bought the
ship out of the caliphate and now
getting that chance to respond
baghdadi
and solamani and the al qaeda leader in
yemen those are two doctrines i believe
in
if we were to apply those doctrines here
i believe ukraine would win
what's your doctrine here's what we have
to know is that the ukrainians are
fighting to win and they're fighting to
win for the very thing that we're able
to do right now to be free to dream
and that is what we say we represent as
americans so we have a great example of
fighting to win there's another part of
it because we've talked about the
military part of it the civilian part of
it also is that we know you see conflict
zone journalists
yes tragically some die
but i have some of my colleagues i'm
going to finish my point most of them
you know over and over we can watch it
on tv why because you can be smart and
you can know where the strategic zones
are when it whether whether it's a you
know a traditional war or or not
and and people can't move so can aid and
so one of the things we're not seeing
we're not seeing by any scale un
organizations
operating they can we're also talking a
lot of they talk about security for aid
and supplies being resourced to
civilians and the military and for
civilians in many cases up armor you
know armored vests are important
so
one of the things i want to say just
about
what it is being there is that of course
there are risks in a conflict zone
but it is not what we picture so often
about a bunch of here we come to save
the day foreigners
you take one car and one truck of
supplies to that border give that truck
and those supplies to ukrainians who
aren't going to leave if you ask them to
and are going to be at risk with or
without our help so we might as well
give them the help they'll bring the
supplies to where they've got to go what
how is that any different than i'm
saying
supply the drones supply the javelins
supply the stingers because i'm not
talking about anybody's doctrine that
got us into a lot of other
the the anti-missile systems they need
the defense systems the
the anti-militar aircraft systems hang
out yeah i agree and i would give them
the migs yeah so we're in agreement we
we absolutely agree and fight the war to
win it and that means to be defeat
russia or let them fight it to win it
because they will that's what i'm saying
let the ukrainians fight themselves we
agree
all right now i want to talk about
because you've been there a lot then you
also went to poland for a period of time
um
and i think most of my audience agrees
if the ukrainian people keep showing the
valor the courage and the willingness to
fight give them the weapons and let them
win
um
let's talk about what you've seen with
your own eyes we we've been showing
pictures almost every night i have to
give a viewer alert what we're about to
show you is horrific and evil and on a
mass scale you've seen the mass graves
we've seen what happened to mario paul
we've seen what happened just outside of
keeve
just in the last two days you've seen
you know
hospitals targeted neighborhoods wiped
out apartment buildings wiped out
and i want to know what you've seen you
tell us how bad it is with your eyes
what you've seen
well i so as we talked about i was there
originally in november
i went back and was there whatever it is
the 37 or whatever it is days ago when
this invasion started
for a couple of days
uh then i went back last week it was
last week two weeks ago my time gets
screwed up with this kind of travel but
uh to the vid
um
you know i'm i
when when i met with president zielinski
my colleagues and i'm making the
documentary
when we went to meet with him it was uh
midday
and
you know we knew that there were
rockets
that were targeting areas just outside
of cu
that there were aerates
sirens a lot and that ultimately when we
when we came out of where we met with
him
there was a
blackout in the city
because of concerns about rockets we
were encouraged not to use our
automobile to drive back because the
lights would could draw a rocket fire
we walked
and because of the experience of what of
what this fight was about and seeing it
in the faces of leadership and air and
and
and not
the only thing we talked about the only
thing we felt
was the deepest sense of heartbreak
first for the ukrainians who were going
to
fight be maimed be injured
be in a war of attrition
but very quickly
i thought
this one
this one my children are gonna feel if
this thing is not one they're gonna feel
it in tangible ways in their life our
our children in america this is
you and i can argue all day but i look
at you and i think you believe in this
country in your way i believe it in mine
and i think it's at risk because the
great dream of it the aspiration of it
with all its diversity because
ukrainians with all their unity they got
a lot of diverse thought over there too
i think we're really at risk if we let
the greatest
most historic in our lifetime fight for
democracy against a
gigantic superpower of a military
intimidation they've done amazingly well
with what they've had outmanned out
gunned yeah so that's what i felt from
my time there
uh going back
the trip live which i was going
principally with the documentary team
but principally driven by the work with
core
because we have 200 staff in and out of
ukraine poland romania
and
which i will make a call for help we
need it we've got
uh incredible
both uh refugee
ukrainians working with us in that 200
we've got ukrainian citizens of poland
and romania uh and then and and others
but half of them half half of our staff
there are now hired up just since this
time um
ukrainians
uh
what so that that trip was targeted on
how to get supplies
into and and by the way just for your
audience
there's been a there's been a little
shift here in the humanitarian world
which is that uh up to uh level four
uh um vests uh
uh body armor uh
that is uh approved uh for humanitarian
organizations to bring and i will say
ukrainians countries poland has been the
most impressive country of all to me in
this they've been the bravest and
they've also absorbed the most
population here's what i want to say
about zielinski
i've been very critical over the years
of ukrainian government corruption
because it stinks to high heaven to me
separate issue for a separate day
and i watch this comedian get elected on
a on a ending corruption platform
this all starts unfolding and what i'll
tell you what impresses me about him
you've met him i have it
is that
there's been many leaders in the world
in similar situations as he's been in
offered asylum i believe he was even
offered asylum here i've been told by my
sources
and they get a private jet they pack it
full of cash
uh other currencies gold and silver yeah
high-heeled shoes high-heeled shoes they
get their ass out right
and he didn't do that he put on his body
armor and he went around the world he's
begging for help from the world not
boots on the ground he's he's asking for
munitions and humanitarian assistance
now that to me
that impresses me
because most other many other leaders
would not have done that i'll give you
the last thought on him
and how
what you think they need the most i'll
let you sum it up
i talked to the mayor
of kiev who's
mayor klitschko who former uh world
heavyweight champion yeah
uh wrote about this is this was in
november this was somebody who very well
could have run against olinsky in the
next election and and perhaps
beaten him
we talked to a lot of people and that
seemed to be the consensus that this
would be competitive
he didn't have a lot of um
praise
for the president
tonight as we're sitting here that same
very powerful figure
uh klitschko
has enlisted
in president zielinski that
commander-in-chief's
military
he's in he's in the fight
so it tells you everything
i mean this is leadership
we talk about leadership
we talk to leaders
uh no one on the planet's been tested in
leadership like this real human being
you're really emotional about this yeah
well i got to tell you something as a
conservative forget our political
differences
i don't want to see one more dead kid in
the street one more innocent woman or or
man dead i don't want to see any more
images in my lifetime of mass graves
like we're seeing yeah there or in
chicago for that matter anywhere i don't
want to see it and we can fix all these
problems if we have the will and desire
to i believe we're the greatest country
on earth
and
i think the ukrainians will win
western europe and america needs to
supply them with the weaponry to win
and if they do they'll be defeating in
my view evil in our time and that's
following the reagan doctrine and
frankly the trump doctrine even though
you don't care about doctrines you know
what the hannity doctrine is i'll give
it to you quick
if you invade a sovereign country
you you forfeit your right to lead a
country and you forfeit your right to
live
meaning vladimir putin has forfeited his
right to live
uh last word well i think that what
would be most interesting about that
conversation is to ask those generals
uh those military commanders in russia
who also have been sanctioned whose
children won't become the united states
for their education or going to england
for their education or a lot of other
places
if i am
i i'm not i don't i don't want to invest
in a conversation not that i don't have
it privately about my feelings about
what should what direct action should
happen to a leader who does that
um
but if there is a god there will be
vengeance beyond all possible
comprehension
vengeance is mine say it the lord just
quoted in a very famous book um
good luck with your work
i hope that this thing this war ends
soon
and i hope they are victorious and i
hope putin gets put right back in the
grave that he deserves to be in for
doing this um and i hope it stops here
and
that's that's it otherwise we gotta
do what happened
that's
that's a that's a bad answer on the
other side you're invited to come back
and talk you'll never talk politics with
me on this show will you
i don't know because i think we're in a
different time and we all have we we all
get we all got to figure out stuff to
talk to you trust me now more than you
did uh i'm not gonna i'm you know i'm
not gonna weigh in on the putin thing no
no you said you said to me
i don't trust you that's what you said
to me do you trust me that i keep my
word
you absolutely kept your word and i so
why don't you trust me
you know what happens is is that there's
a lot of physical therapy necessary
after a big car accident
you don't get it all done in a day all
right
um i wish
our prayers are with the innocent
victims of this conflict yes dying and i
wish you'd like and the heroes you were
fighting for
but we'll come back next time we'll
battle over hugo chavez or something fun
that's an interesting conversation all
right all right seriously thank you for
being with us hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else